hey guys I'm Brian right and I'm Alana
cold oh yes good for you I wanna club
youtuber founder on fullscreen awesome
mmm multi-channel network that's what
you guys are well no not no that's what
fullscreen is oh she's a really clever
youtuber I came across her channel and
she does a lot of vlogging she's [ __ ]
awesome I actually can pay attention to
the videos because I only watching my
videos let's face it about me in my life
I thought what better video to watch
with another youtuber of fellow youtuber
then a viral video it's called man
smacks the soul out of girl on the NY
subway I think he's in a snacker real
hard Alana's comfortable on the channel
I love it I love it she's going to say
comments like that
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
they are like murdering each other right
now
[Music]
[Music]
Wow he's after really hard he did smack
the soul out of that woman Wow
she has no more soul no how about Ramat
izing that must have been for her well
then again she seems like she's been
through a lot of [ __ ] already yeah she
ha ha yeah you know so it's not a big
deal and then there was a guy beating
what was it a girl her guy I'm pretty
sure that was a guy who jumped in yeah
as a man should but honestly if you got
smacked
I probably run away away so would you
defend the girl who got smacked though
it depends on the girl her her she's
really up in his face she shouldn't have
okay she shouldn't have been slapping
anyone no she does not just I probably
would have done something yeah this male
instinct in me just goes I have to
defend I think I would just run off the
bus or train when I was this is a train
yeah a subway station in Crenshaw
apparently I should have known some
people think I might be a little bit
racist I'll have you know Alana is a
quarter african-american that's right
first sort of black chick to have on the
channel it's really squeaky it's a
Swedish couch I don't know what happened
to it it was perfect when I first bought
it but now it squeaks I bet you can
guess why I guess what's your guess you
jump on it I jump on it and I touch
myself while I'm jumping on it thank you
guys for recommending that video if you
guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where
we're so I don't know
Alana has her Channel cool vlogging ciao
serious you watch her videos and you are
pulled in and she puts the camera like
this close to her face yeah I want to
put your face up to the camera would you
that's how close she films so if you
want to see more of that with that face
that she just made you check out her
videos
okay dress how do you say that Druce
aisle
girls still need Roesel man it's joe
seal you know yes my name gross seal
have you heard that name before yeah
you're just assuming I didn't Crenshaw
that's how you're assuming it's just
that just bow or whatever the [ __ ] you
did seal I am crushing on Alyssa be
crazy yeah she's cool lol I hope this
isn't weird but I wanted more videos
she's not here thanks for talking a lot
about her I don't want a shout-out well
dude now you're getting one I love your
videos and you all are just amazing and
funny I hope you make a comedy movie one
day well guess what
it's in the works now Alana's writing it
for us oh it's the biography of Ryan
right that's right I'm having I'm having
her do it I wasn't aware and now I am
it's gonna be all authentic about how I
you know save people I saved a lot of
people from fires and car accidents car
accidents and and microwaves there you
go see
that's why we need a Lana to do this
yeah because she knows how to fill in
the gaps
is that a sex joke what is it can it be
as actually okay filling the gaps oh
yeah fill in the gaps fill in the gaps
thank you yours I'll shadow cast where
the hell is my shout-out shadow cast
it's here right now what do you think
shadow cast means Alana
I think he's casting a shadow wow the
witty timing on you is genius the
ability to just come home what clever
material shadow cast yes you are casting
the shadows because my friend you have a
Dark Soul we want to pull you out of it
we're hoping this video helps you cope
with whatever darkness you're going
through or just stay in the dark side
yeah because we kind of don't know you
so it doesn't really affect our life
dark magic did you see what they did the
white powder sign Oh what was that
what's the white powder sign I forget I
thought it was this oh shoot I didn't
mean that
what's the white power sign
yeah wavier can yeah [ __ ] you anyway
guys I'm caught up on all the shoutouts
so you can go to facebook.com slash
little real reject shoutouts that's
where you say it because I don't want to
go through all these comments anymore
50,000 subscribers now Ilana you think I
have time to read all these islands
commit me now to visit when YouTube is
your full-time job I ain't got time I
only got time this seems like power out
of my day the rest who knows what else
is gonna happen it's Anna jumping on
your couch jumping on my couch while
doing fun things to myself I won't watch
that